welcome to this video Oh am playing kill
yard again International Master Carlo de
Moura from from Italy one of the
frequent opponents and bow I knew I
didn't have a good score against him but
I have three wins 10 losses no draw
which is really quite remarkable as our
playing strength is not differing so
much ok so let's see we've got a
somewhat wacky opening line the strange
mix of a sloth london whatever and what
I want to do is I want to get the pawn
back really really badly
efore Bishop c4 would be nice to get in
he's taking quite a mom yeah they're
interesting possibilities one being a
twin b6 baby I just not have sex I don't
know not quite sure what what he is
thinking about maybe a quick counter
play with e five like 9075 this is maybe
become an interesting option because i
have f 3 plate and neglected the five
square a bit or like here I re5 d takes
mmm something like that is what he wants
to do it seems they're not not much not
much I can do to prevent it I can
actually think about taking
I don't like to take now that's all so
long castles no probably better not
now it's a very aggressive player very
often taking some risks yeah lie like
that i mean i don't know it's probably
good but it's also it also entailed some
some some risk okay 95 is 95 many this
is not very comfortable there is this
the spinning idea with c5 and there also
is Bishop takes f3 sometimes okay I go
here I don't like it very much but I
don't and that was c5 I don't I didn't
see anything else Bishop f3 mother's
Bishop b5 but sugar 3 GF Knight f3 check
night XD for it's not very good yeah as
I mentioned he's a very enterprising
player I don't get it yet but well I
have to take a Quincy five Quincy fire
very interesting okay so I need to
probably play here check
to do so quickly not fall behind on the
clock takes Queen takes is interesting
and takes all night excess Queen III
check we're taking what the Queen can
get can get tricky
don't don't have a check at the moment
he saw the sea threatening maybe bishop
f seven and twelve maybe a 93 of course
long castles
yeah probably i need to do it anyway no
use in spending so much time now but
that is bishop f7 when besides other
possible moves
Bishop I've sown
I just play I would just play Bishop of
79 hope for the best
not sure what I'm threatening maybe
night be three but is it that dangerous
night be five versus is a threat maybe
with rock the aid okay maybe I go here
the ship f7 is strapping the Queen
okay okay let's just speed up here I
have seen that he can take but I feel
that I have I have a good a good
initiative after that as my queen that
is very good only six opens I didn't
seem okay I can I can I can do that
Queenie five Queen trade wasn't it
wasn't really helping
Wow very very tough position
rookie for Bishop f5 Wow maybe he and 28
I don't know I cannot calculate this
terribly terribly complicated came as I
take amazing he didn't lose any material
them I just want to push the two pockets
cam time warning
check check why he's defending this
amazingly well with was just so little
time that's really really strong and now
it's even better which which I can
hardly believe but he had ten seconds on
the clock check check
unbelievable defense White forfeits on
time I even lose because he has got a
pawn left yeah I'm admitted I don't ever
really don't care I mean how how could
you defend this position in 10 seconds
I'm unbelievable chairs just totally
winning why wasn't it totally winning
for me at five it's still + Chang this
is wrong look g3s the move okay I was
just so stunned that I'm not winning
immediately check but I didn't even look
at the clock okay here i'm getting at
least nah not sure not sure this is
maybe I am yeah that's probably a win
check here okay at the end I was just
not looking at the clock i mean i can i
can draw however I want amazing yeah I
forgot that he has pawns left early it's
it's not really something that troubles
me too much just that that that I
couldn't win the position i mean this
distance is troubling
guides the plated amazingly well with no
time on the clock normal player just
just breaks down without any any sort of
fight IAM who alright thanks for
watching